So today I have the pleasure of talking
to Alberto of Italiano Automatico and
we're going to talk about more than
just Italian, we're going to talk
about Alberto's interests and how
these interests led him to create his
Italiano Automatico website and how
it helps other people learn Italian.
Remember, if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notification.
If you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
Okay.
Alberto.
Before we get started, first of all,
we just had a conversation in Italian.
I'm tired because I never speak Italian.
So I was struggling.
Now it's Alberto is turned to
struggle, although he doesn't
struggle in English I'll bet.
Can you briefly introduce yourself
and, and, uh, Italiano Automatico.
Absolutely Steve, I'm going to talk
very fast because it's a lot of things
and, uh, I want to give a short version.
So basically first of all, thank you so
much for having me here on your channel.
It's like a dream for me because you
are part of the change in my life.
When after 10 years of studying in
school, English, I tried one day
to watch some movies and, uh, watch
TV like CNN and stuff like that.
And I was curious to see, am
I gonna understand something.
And my surprise was I'm not understanding
much so after 10 years, and I
started typing online polyglot, not
polygot, but how to learn languages.
And who did I find?
Steve?
Of course, Steve, there was Steve,
Steve Kaufmann, and then I went
to the roots of the method and two
other people, but really at the
beginning it was Luca and Steve.
And after school, I remember
when I was 16, I came back and
watched hours like seven hours of
videos both from Steve and Luca.
And it revolutionized the way I was
thinking about not only language
learning, but the way things are
done in school, that in general,
they are not always the best.
And it was the first time
I was thinking about that.
And, uh, from that period of
my life, from that period of
my life, I started to go deep.
I discovered many polyglots and I
thought, Hey, uh, let me try learn some
languages by myself outside of school.
And I, I tried to learn some French,
Spanish, and Romanian outside, and
after one year I had better level,
a better level in these languages
than in English, after 10 years.
And, uh, I also improved my English a lot.
I never put effort on improving
pronunciation in English because I
mostly speak with non, non-natives.
And sometimes, uh, you know, it's an
effort that you can decide to put, uh, or
not, uh, on improving your pronunciation.
But, um, it was more of a choice
and, um, but I saw huge improvement,
uh, applying what Steve was sharing.
And that's when I found also
something that I liked that, that
moment to work out as well and run.
And I said, okay, Steve has some
videos, for example, interviewing
Luca in different languages.
Let me listen to a video of Steve in
a language I'm learning while I run.
So I'm doing three things together.
I'm training my body.
I'm changing, I'm learning a new
language and I'm learning something new.
So three things together.
I'm learning how to learn a language,
learning Spanish and training my body.
And that's where everything started.
And, uh, I decided to open a
Italian Automatico, which, well, I
want to try to create content that
combines these three things in life.
That's it Steve, sorry.
You know, I find that very interesting
because, uh, I read quite a few
books on how the brain learns.
And in one of these books, it was
pointed out that if a parent reads a
story to their child, and it's a simple
children's story and the parent is not
very interested in the story or they
know the story the child learns less
in terms of language from that than
if the parent is an expert in, I don't
know, nuclear physics or something, but
reads something that they are passionate
about, that they enjoy, that child will
learn more because the child will pick
up on the fact that the parent is more
enthusiastic is not bored by what they're
reading, but is enthusiastic about what
they're reading or what they're saying.
And I think what I get from Italian
Automatico is that obviously you are very
enthusiastic about learning, about staying
fit and you read widely on the subject.
And then you're able to provide advice
to your learners so that they in turn are
not only picking up Italian and they're
learning something about staying fit or
other self help things, but they pick up
on your enthusiasm in explaining that,
and that enthusiasm is going to, if
they can learn their Italian from your
enthusiasm and if they're interested
in those subjects, they're going to
learn much better than if they read
some, you know, textbook on Italian.
So I think that's a tremendous service.
Uh, um, what were some of the
examples that you looked at before
you set up your own channel.
So nice question, because after I
discovered the, you guys, like in the
style of polyglots really, uh, polygot
channels, I started to improve my
languages and, uh, and learn new ones.
So I did need some content that
was, uh, as you always say, that
intermediate content that is not too
easy and boring and not too hard and
not understandable, but in the middle,
which is compelling and interesting.
So at that moment, I found,
for example, Effortless English
for my English, A J Hoge.
That's what I learned.
The seven rules.
I listened to them many times.
Then français Authentique, which is my
best friend now we speak weekly, Johan.
And, uh, and I went into this
route to learn other languages.
Then after one or two years I
said hey, why can't I create
some content for Italian?
And that's how it started.
It's interesting.
This idea that, that not, not everyone
who's interested in learning languages
is going to be interested in being fit.
However, uh, I would certainly recommend
it because I think that that the way our
brain learns there are sort of chemical
reactions taking place in our brain.
Right?
Steve, I love that you mention that.
I was this morning uh, I'm
waking up now at, uh, 4.15.
I usually woke up different
times during my life.
Uh, either 5, 6, 4.15, uh,
mostly, uh, it was that range.
And, uh, uh, there is a book called The
Spark that explains how we learn better
during exercise because of the oxygen
and everything that you will make.
Oh really?
I didn't know that.
Yes, there is a, there is a book
explaining all of that happens also why
you learn better while also exercising,
you feel more awake, et cetera.
And I just, this morning I was
lifting weights I was listening to
a podcast in other languages and,
you know, I felt that I was more
alert also to the, to the language.
So that's why I really, as you
said, I really recommend, uh, uh,
combining these working out, learning
a language and learning something.
Because really then that hour
that most people say, I cannot
find the hour to do that.
I mean, it's the most powerful
hour you can have in your day.
I mean, one hour doing three things
to improve your life and your day.
Because for example, I listen to a lot
of, uh, positive also concepts, not
because I don't want to look at reality,
but there is so much negativity in the
news and everything that I needed to...
because, because then I'm more focused
also in my day while I work and I can
share a bit of hope and positivity
instead of complaints, right?
So, and I also learned about business in
the podcast, everything that you want.
Right now it's so easy
to find content that...
it's so easy to do also.
There are so many podcasts in, in
different languages, uh, on business,
marketing, self-help, history, like
even, uh, like, uh, ... in Italy is
phenomenal source of Italian content.
And nowadays we have the option of
putting them on an automatic transcription
service so that we can get a transcript
and bringing in to bring it into LingQ.
But yeah, I used to go jogging,
listening to ... which is hated by
school children, but for me, it was this
exotic, you know, 17th century Italy.
I loved it.
I've gone skiing through, you
know, cross the country skiing,
listening to a Russian novel.
However, there are, you can't be
a hundred percent, like right now
I've discovered a kettlebell high
intensity workouts on YouTube.
I don't know if you've tried
those kettlebell workouts.
They're tremendous, but then I have
to be watching the YouTube cause I
have to follow what they're doing.
So I can't be listening to my language
while I'm doing my kettlebell workouts.
But nothing's perfect.
Uh, for example, you are in a high
intensity workout that you can
not really focus on the language.
So it's totally fine like also to
have either music or to watch the
video, but it's more the concept
that you always shared of using also
your, uh, uh, "dead time" you say in
English, you have your mind free to
listen to a language and, uh, and you
will be otherwise wasting the time.
I know many want to stay in silence.
Okay.
Of course, of course.
But apart of that time, for me, it
was all, all of the time 90% after I
listened to you and Luca, I was obsessed.
It was the whole day, the whole
day, listening to things while I was
cooking while I was taking a shower
while I was walking, on the bus and
you see how much you can learn during
the time, it's like, It's insane.
You don't have to be a hundred percent
concentrated focused the whole time.
That's the other thing people don't
realize you can be wanderingout,
you lose track, come back in.
That's all fine.
60% focus.
It's okay.
Especially because you are going to...
the concept is that you're going
to listen to these things multiple
times also to learn the language.
So it doesn't matter if you miss 40%,
it's the learning loop of repetition.
So you're not stressed, or I
need to listen to everything.
It's going there in the background
and I'm doing my things.
And, uh, I pick up some things every time.
That's it.
Absolutely.
Well listen, I recommend to anyone
who hasn't started learning Italian,
or is already learning Italian,
please go to Italiano Automatico to
get a dose of enthusiasm and also
to work on your Italian language.
Thank you very much
Alberton, great conversation.
Thank you Steve.
Thank you so much.